he been playing video games I got modern
warfare call of duty and it's fun it's
definitely funny but it's different it's
a lot different I feel like than when I
was young
these give the video games now you can't
really lose every time you get a little
they got a checkpoint they call it you
check oh you got the checkpoint whenever
you start back again you start right
here buckaroo good luck good luck young
buck you're gonna be you're gonna do
great out there then when I was young I
remember you had to look if you we knew
like you had a couple of lives and if
you lost them all guess what you had to
start over at the beginning of the game
and it was insane I remember if you got
to the point where you gonna fight the
bad guy remember you're gonna fight
Bowser dude I would pause the game dude
I would take a break you know I get my I
get my brother dude doing massage doing
massage my hands I be putting chalk on
my hands I'll be doing cleaning jerks in
the yard I would get ready if you were
about to fight Bowser I would get a rest
for two days just leave it leave the
screen on I would be there was no steve
it-- grandma she's my good-luck charm
invite her over grandma would drive down
from illinois' if I'm fighting Bowser
you had to prepare this was it this was
the big showdown you weren't gonna get a
million chances at it remember you would
do everything you you you know you'd
have maybe your dad would even come back
here and seen you in years he shows up
to help you [ __ ] to help you with us to
watch you fight him and he's in disguise
because you don't want your mom trying
to get any of the money he owes and then
he leaves you lose and he's gone
but you know but there's rumors that it
was him it was just a different time and
if you were at the if you were fighting
the champ the Bowser and now it's like
you're at the end they got a movie in
between and make you feel comfortable
you can restart a million times at the
end you can't lose you can't really lose
but it was different back then you had
do remember sometimes you'd have to put
something in the machine the machine
broke after a while it broken yet to put
something there to hold the game in
place or yet have your sister sit there
and hold the game remember that
hold the game she's like I'm not holding
the game you'd am holding the game or
you ain't eating and she would hold the
game but then she would get nervous or
something she would sneeze and move both
her hands to cover her mouth because she
had manners and she and she and she she
[ __ ] the game up and everybody would
be pissed and you wouldn't forget it
even at Christmas times you wouldn't get
her nothing and you because you couldn't
forget that good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or watch this
one watch this one watch this one
watches one